-This film is, in many ways,
about Judaism,
about things that survive
over generations,
about the different
relationships you can have
with your religion.
There is a joke that is so funny
about, basically, where th
100-year-old great-grandfather
finds out that Jonas Salk
cured polio,
and his first question is
"Was he Jewish?"
-Was he Jewish? Yeah.
That taps into
a very Jewish thing,
which is Jews are very proud
of other Jewish accomplishments,
and he's so psyched when h
finds out Jonas Salk was Jewish.
And nothing evidences this
probably, phenomena more tha
the book
"Great Jews in Sports"
which is a book
every Jewish person has
which is a small book,
but that is how much we want
to know what every Jewish
accomplishment in history
ever was, that we will tak
the six great Jews in sports
and make an entire book
about them.
-[ Laughs ] You mentioned --
Was it from the jump,
was it the idea that you would
play both characters?
Was there a time that -- I mean,
'cause it's not necessaril
a situation where that you had
to play both characters,
but it's such an accomplishmen
both technically
and as an actor, because you had
to take months off
between doing second halve
of the seasons, right?
Well, no, we did the whole
first half as Herschel,
and then we went back and di
the whole other half as Ben.
And it's not something
I went into lightly,
and I actually tried
to get out of it several times
We actually did a table read
where Ike Barinholtz read
the Herschel role at one point
and he was hilarious.
And I remember thinking, like,
"We don't need me to do both
of them. We got Ike!"
But people, the other
filmmakers, really wanted me
to play both roles,
and, eventually,
I wrapped my head
around doing it.
But, yeah, it was
incredibly complicated.
But what I did find is I do no
like working with other actors
and I do prefer
working with myself.
-[ Laughs ]
-Actors are tough,
and when you remove
as many of them
from the equation as possible,
it makes things a lot easier
-Although, I think --
I would like to provide yo
the opportunity,
because you had a stand-in
and I imagine that was somebod
who, you know,
there's not going to be a lo
of glory in being off-camera
-Yes.
-But, obviously, this was
an incredibly important role
in this film.
-Yes, Ian Poake was his name
and he played opposite me
in almost every scene.
And I remember telling him
specifically, like,
the better job you do, the les
it will seem like you exist.
-Really?
-Like thriving for a complet
evaporation on your part,
and that's the bull's-eye
you're trying to hit.
And then he really did
an amazing job,
and it was, like, in some ways
a very, like, selfless --
you know, he was compensated
but, in some ways,
a very selfless thing
for him to do
was essentially act in an entire
movie with the understanding
he would be removed
from it later,
and he played both roles.
Whoever I wasn't playing,
he would play,
and he was very -- he was great.
And he was very,
like, malleable
and would get my blocking.
And sometimes, I would tell him,
like, "Just don't talk.
I'm hearing what you're saying
as I'm thinking of it,
but you just sit there
and look at me,"
and he was like,
"Okay, no problem."
And he was a great partner
It was actually a lot of fun
and he made my performance
much better, yeah.
-I was really taken how quickl
you forget it is happening
at a separate time,
and I imagine so much work
went into that.
And, ultimately, like,
you were saying,
like, you have to, like,
do all of this work to make it
then look invisible
for the audience, too.
Sort of remember --
not giving anything away -
but there's a moment later
in the film
where you start looking
more alike.
You remember, "Oh.
This is Ben, not Herschel.
-Yeah. No. It was another
one of those things
where, like, the better jo
we did, the less it would seem
like we did something.
It would be like
if the funnier you were,
the less funny you seemed.
The more our jobs
were done correctly,
the less we seemed like we wer
achieving anything special
or complicated in any way,
shape, or form,
which was a weird goal
to be chasing, but, yeah.
It was a worthy cause,
I thought, if nothing else
-You're also finding time
for another worthy cause.
I have seen photos of some
of your ceramic work lately.
These are ashtrays?
-I make ashtrays. I make vases
I make all sorts of things
Yeah.
This is an ashtray I made.
-The part that I really want
to point out --
that is a lighter holder
on top, yes?
Well, no.
You can put your joint in there,
and then you can put
your lighter in here.
-Ohh, look at that.
-Two little separate things.
I have a few different
designs around.
-Now, do you keep those al
for yourself?
Do they stay in the family
Have you gifted them to anyone
-I've given some away.
I'll send you a vase,
if you want one.
-That'd be very nice.
Thank you.
[ Both laugh ]
-You got one
coming coming your way.
-Hey, man, it's always
such a pleasure to see you
Congrats on the film.
It's really great.
-Thank you so much.
-And I look forward
to the next time.
-Yeah, maybe one day, the worl
will go back to normal. Yeah
-I would like that.
-That would be nice.
Have a good one.
-All right,
Have a good one, sir.